did you miss
me oh Lord help me get through this
game everyone's a liar I can't be
trusted I'm trying to win she's a stone
cold killer it's just gossip I think she
could be banished this is some
bull this is getting
intense welcome to an all new season of
strategy betrayal
sabotage and
murder higher Stakes Allan's dropping
another bomb Shield this guy is the
silent
slaughterer diabolical twist she's the
traitor why would I want to murder her
boyfriend come on hurry go go go and a
killer all celebrity cast people keep
throwing the housewives out there as
traitor I don't think they've got it in
them this is not the Bachelor and I
don't have to kiss your ass for
Rose who will win a quarter of a million
dollar I was born ready and who will win
a plot in my graveyard I'm coming after
that
goal you want to work together and get
somebody
out she talk about me I'm going to have
to the first signs of
deception I'm going to take care of her
once and for all there's no friendships
in this game I find you highly annoying
it's just a ton of
Chaos
hold on to your kils deities the games
are just
beginning too
much so how does it feel to be the
second best dressed guy I'd say back
off